les fêtes de pâques avec
traditionnellement ses excès de
gourmandise devant l'irrésistible
chocolat peu importe contrairement aux
idées reçues le chocolat n'est pas
mauvais pour la santé au contraire voici
de quoi déculpabiliser les amateurs à
tennie temps benoît thevenet pierre
moscovici difficile à digérer fait
grossir donne de la cne le chocolat a
bien du mal à se débarrasser d'une
mauvaise réputation
et pourtant au xviie siècle on lui
reconnaissait des vertus fortifiantes et
digestives les chocolatiers
d'aujourd'hui s'appuie sur des études
scientifiques pour montrer que le
chocolat est bon pour la santé
à une condition tout de même qu'il soit
de grande qualité la santé du
consommateur devient alors un argument
supplémentaire pour dénoncer les
récentes directives européennes bon
chocolat vrai chocolat donc le chocolat
qu'on ouvre on va continuer à faire
malgré les directives n'ont plus assez
un chocolat pur cacao pur beurre de
cacao avec qu'à travailler fait dans de
bonnes conditions c'est très bon pour la
santé
c'est dans le produit de base la fève de
cacao que l'on trouve les secrets
médicinaux du chocolat un chocolat noir
n'est donc pas seulement moins riches en
sucres et en graisses
il contient aussi plus de substances
bénéfiques à l'organisme et les vertus
du cacao sont impressionnantes
le chocolat un effet positif important
souvent méconnu c'est le fait qu'il est
bénéfique au niveau du cholestérol dont
il fait baisser le cholestérol dans le
sang et les tanins qu'il contient
favorise disons une amélioration de
l'état des artères donc on peut
considérer que c'est un bénéfice de
prévention cardiovasculaire par ailleurs
il contient des substances tonique
caféine théobromine et des substances
disons anti stress comme le magnésium et
même des substances un peu anti
dépressifs comme la phényléthylamine nom
un peu barbare on convoi qui a un côté
dynamisant anxyolitiques anti stress
bonne nouvelle la gourmandise peut faire
du bien l'organisme mais attention le
chocolat reste un aliment comme les
autres en abuser vous conduirait tout
droit à l'indigestion